I will continue we get more this this
moment in the exchange is present
throughout the chemo mother but a lot of
other stuff is present in the keep on
was up so contrary to kind of what you
hear is like all the trainings of
firefighters you train now if you want
to develop a skill get as many reps in
at that thing you're trying to develop
and the way you get as many reps in is
by isolating it from all the other
things so you can just keep repeating
that moment over and over and over okay
and for the sake of this drill we're not
going to concentrate on bootcamp but you
all know that if you want to progress in
the art you have to learn how to accept
falling into young faces you have to
learn how to maintain your center
connection and center engagement right
don't practice disengagement
disconnection but if you are one of
those new kids you just provide you're
just providing a better training
environment for naga today okay I'm not
gonna go around and correct you on that
but please don't think that in the
absence of my Corrections that you're
doing okay you're not but they're doing
better for how lame you are okay you
guys got that okay so the drill we don't
I don't want you to go like wait inside
outside is that's taken away from rec
time but generally one hand is on the
outside the one hand is on the
but if I come in with me like that I'm
not gonna go who's only you're just
taking away repertoire so just make
contact who kit is going to push at my
chest and push with this hand they can
push with the other hand you see and I
go and then I'll find the connection and
I'll push out it's just about the rest
okay rest and reps and then some
pointers reps and reps so some of the
things so as he's going here right to
see his linear energy what we're doing
is not this see I'm not moving out of
the way so I've seen a lot of thought
you're going like this and then you're
pulling on us so here's how you can show
that that I'm not doing that as he's
pushing you see he's not going past me
when I move out when I move out of the
way so we're moving at my pace that at
any point this can't just stop you see
that there's a structural integrity to
it okay so I'm gonna you're gonna keep
doing your push and you can see I'm
slowing him down I'm turning him you see
okay
I return
[Music]
so you all like this you know here like
this that's totally different right okay
so I'm here connected wool so you if you
if you're getting it really easy maybe
even if you're not right do it at a
slower pace
[Music]
instead of going like this maybe try not
moving at all to test yourself - stop
doing deviation and momentum stuff
okay so plays if you got a whole hour of
this kind of stuff
[Music]
okay let's get more pointers so
theoretically theoretically I think you
just need another leverage point in the
equation to get into work meaning I have
his energy right and then what what I
need to do is a third energies at
another point that I can vector off of
so this case is that round and that's
the first one that we're teaching but I
don't think as he's going right I think
you can get a third energy inside your
body too you see I'm doing that so off
of my other muscles my skeletal system
my spine all that kind of stuff so if
that's the case right go ahead you're
fine
right look at me like this so can I
still do it push yes right I can still
do it
but it's harder right and this is not
martially viable there's no sports right
there's this sports like that there's no
fighting like that so some of the things
you want to make sure you do is that
your needs are met you're standing
straight up like this okay and it's from
tension so if you have to also relax oh
I bet I have to bend my knees I have to
let the weight of my upper body spread
through my feet right so I feel the
ground you guys got that I have to make
sure my arches aren't caving in that the
outside of my foot is down so energy is
running around the outside of my body
don't lean you're gonna find that harder
again he comes in right
and I can lean and it'll still work but
it's harder to learn that okay let's
stand up over your body
boom boom boom and relax and breathe
don't push with your legs so you guys
share and watch my knees you know that's
gonna have to take power away keep your
knees where they are maybe even try
dropping up you see not saltiness
watch your head angle it to starts to
keep your posture on some of you so
again the headache goes loud unfortunate
go ahead and push ten angles not
important once you're doing it but at
the beginning it's hard so watch your
head angle keep the crown at the top
bend your knees relax feel your feet
spread okay let's go
[Music]
okay so here's our doer who can't write
if she goes and so when I push you see
she lifts her arms okay that's not the
problem good okay okay so here I go and
I'm going to push she's pushing on me
with her weight you feel that
okay so they keep pushing on this
shoulder she just pushed more on on me
you see that that's the point then so I
push on the shoulder right and then I
can use that her touch on my shoulder
but when I do what do you think she's
gonna do do you see how she's going to
do that so my motion has to be dynamic
won't Oh
same thing here DC and collapsed it
doesn't it's not wrong so I go to push
it has to go into her body
[Music]
so an easy one right are you gonna push
here you say she brought it around you
see that
so not wrong just keep aiming it so it
was you an easy one that you can see
when I push this has been your arms okay
so I've been my arm her arm easy it does
the connect so as I go she bends her arm
fine her senator who do that movement
okay it's not any different than the
single push do you see you have
connection on the single push right well
you just keep that dynamic keep that
dynamic she just let it go over there
right so he keeps Amy it's got to keep
moving okay
so let's do also next development is try
to remember your friction don't go any
faster that you're losing your friction
so keep it so even though you're on the
outside right and you go to push on this
it shouldn't slide it's it's an
extension of that idea keep the
connection in there so even though I'm
not grabbing him I'm actually able to
turn him do you see that though right
you can look up on the outside you see
that it's doable in the same way that as
I'm going here I hear him on the inside
right so I lift my arm can slide if I
wanted to right but it can keep moving
in you see that it's the same thing then
you have to do with the disc
okay so you're just writing the energy
Here I am on the outside don't go around
the arm keep pressing into the energy
Lydon get that you guys stop good more
few more points one don't don't set up
like keep on you get it this is not like
it he own is not a self defense
situation what do you have an attacker
and defender well we're even we isolated
more from within people so don't stand
up like yeah I'm saying we just make
contact you see how I'm standing okay
but at the same time don't lose the
starting point has been making
irrelevant but don't lose your martial
viability so yeah I'm standing like this
do you see I'm on my my tightrope okay
again this is not a fighting stance okay
this is a specialized stance made for a
certain situation don't stand with your
feet on the line and you're like this
okay dad like if you're gonna fight got
it so neutral poet toe you know
alignment that kind of thing you decide
your particular style of offense and
defense on how wide that line is between
your toe in front of your back everyone
about that so stop doing this because it
does a couple things so we'll make a
side note here is as you code you're
starting to toss the hot up whenever you
yield yield one way or another you're
starting to twist the heart and then now
you're decompressing it it's not swollen
okay so here stand so that it's
in the center okay don't do this stuff
this you you I don't want to say it's
not theoretically possible but
definitely if it is you are becoming
less martially efficient and it's going
to be really hard to get it there to
develop it from that point okay so back
to Marshall viability again don't do
like these things like that you see that
see my hands to move out of it and I go
hey let's fight does this look like what
it's style it's at okay so my hands are
always in front of me do you see so move
out of the way and you see okay so I've
seen a lot of this yielding you see Oh
[Music]
keep your hands where boom boom boom
that's where your techniques are right
cook you all right cause you not yet
right boom you see they're always here
your Center so don't let your hands
crossover as you see like that okay if
you want to go over there look how I
stepping you see you see I'm doing that
so keep that center line warm boom
[Music]
another test you feel you're getting it
is so right right now look how I'm doing
an entry in the projection alright let's
let's see if I could get him to just
fall and hit the spot that so I'm loaded
him onto my spot
this is different
he's gonna fall on my spot boom
Oh
[Music]
you guys see that thank you try